[Music]  62% of European websites use geo  blocking which discriminates against  online shoppers based on their  nationality or where they live  Parliament is adopting new legislation  to ensure the rules are the same for  everyone the parliament is reforming the  --use emissions trading system to cut  carbon emissions faster and to fund  low-carbon innovation members are  discussing the new composition of the  European Parliament including how to  redistribute seats left of a clipped  after Britain leaves the EU Croatia's  Prime Minister Andre pling kovitch is to  debate the future of the European Union  with members of parliament Parliament is  to set up a special committee to look  into the e use authorization procedure  for pesticides